you've obviously filmed the last series
of Game of Thrones going out in the new
year what was it like when they said cut
for the last time on your final scene I
burst into tears you know it's weird
thing I'm not sad about it ending
I'm just feel very joyous about it
anything and having completed it but it
doesn't make it any less emotional and
the first pilot of Game of Thrones was
described by its producers as a disaster
what did you make of it when you when he
first made it I was doing I mean it's
like oh this isn't this is fun I'm in a
TV show I had no idea whether it was
gonna be big or a success or anything
and it was apparently it was a disaster
I still haven't seen it
they they they blackmail me every now
and again with threatening that they'll
release bits on YouTube because
apparently was it was terrible and I
have this awful wig and but now it
sometimes you with with great sort of
with things that end up being huge
successes they start with huge failures
and the fact it is such a global
phenomenon I mean are there any
countries you can go to where you don't
get recognized not that I've found
although this is helping you know I'm
now I'm I'm now you know I get
recognized a lot less now I've got less
hair and everybody is Charlie we got a
whole bunch of new Game of Thrones to
talk about season 8 trailer Kit
Harington talking about his final scene
again and I have a clip of Robb Stark
rewatching the red wedding which is
actually kind of funny so we got to
break it down there's a new round of the
giveaway for George RR Martin's new book
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so we just broke this down top 5
style CC XP is the big Brazil comic-con
happening later this week as of me
posting this video HBO is sending Game
of Thrones in a bigger way than they've
ever done before dan and Dave are both
going they're sending Maisie Williams
and sophie Turner Maisie Williams just
posted a funny clip of her trying to
tell everybody and all her fans that she
was going to be there and John Bradley
is going as well they'll probably
announce some more people throughout the
week the reason why CC XP is a really
big deal is because
it's the biggest comic-con in the
southern hemisphere that's happening
between now and when Game of Thrones
premieres next year typically what
happens is as Studios will send footage
for all their big movies that are
premiering earlier in the following year
so like movies the premiere in February
and March because in the United States
all the really big conventions where
they would do that like San Diego
comic-con typically happened in the
summer and that's not happening till
after a game of Thrones premiers so for
you guys have probably noticed the last
several weeks HBO has been ramping up on
their game of throws press tour they've
also been releasing special character
promos for each of the main characters
highlighting their journeys so far just
sort of counting down once per week
through the main cast they just dropped
a Cersei promo but they've already done
Arya and they've done Tyrion so far
pretty safe bet that they'll save Jon
Snow and Daenerys for the last two weeks
then release another big promo for
season 8 footage and that'll probably be
sometime in January but because CC XP is
such a big deal typically Studios show
off clips now usually they don't drop
those online but odds are pretty good
that Dan and Dave will bring something
either behind the scenes clip or some
new promo that we haven't seen we've
gotten a little bit of season 8 footage
so far but nothing that you could really
call a full trailer whatever ends up
happening I will totally break it down
most of the really big trailer footage
they're probably holding because it
requires a lot of special effects and
involves a lot of dragons and big battle
scenes that stuff will probably drop in
January so if they drop any promos
between now and the end of the year
it'll probably just be characters
talking to each other and stuff that
doesn't require a lot of big explosions
three kit harington was joking about
that failed pilot again the terrible
wigs that were somehow even worse than
the wigs that we saw on the second
version of the pilot they've never
released it fully online before in the
only leaks that we've ever gotten
weren't really leaked so much it was
just a version of the script and then
there were bits of footage from the very
first original promo HBO ever aired for
the series it's that one with everyone
sitting on the Iron Throne and there's a
quick shot of the Mad King killing
Brandon and Rickard stark even though we
never actually got to see that flashback
on the actual series they did wind up
doing the flashback in season six of
Jaime Lannister killing the Mad King but
my hope is is that after season eight
airs and they release it on blu-ray and
it's had some time to settle in some
future year they will finally release
some footage of that
original pilot or summer will
quote-unquote accidentally leak it - he
talks about his final scene and just the
relief of having felt like they achieved
some great work of art in the last ten
years remember it's only been eight
seasons but it's been closer to ten
years for most of the actors and the
producers now he's able to cut his hair
which is how you get the Kit Harington
weird-looking mustache because he's
doing a play right now but in that
season eight episode one preview
breakdown that I did a little while ago
Entertainment Weekly had said something
interesting about that final scene when
they were doing their set visit that it
was in a new place that the producers
built and had never been seen before on
Game of Thrones
they didn't say if it was in a new
geographical location or if it was just
them rebuilding a new version of a
previous existing set like Winterfell or
King's Landing that had been destroyed
in one of the big battles but if season
eight is supposed to end in a place that
we've never seen before let me know in
the comments what you think that place
is in number one this is just funny
Richard Madden himself did a special
featurette where he just rewatched the
red wedding and reacted to it so I'll
play that clip here and have us to watch
this because the last time I watched it
they did it with Michelle Fairley who
plays my mother and obviously spent most
of scene and I think we would actually
look into tears by the end of it quite
embarrassingly so let's hope I don't cry
today side note the drummer in the
sequence is actually the drummer from
Coldplay yeah
[Music]
your grave so funny I still watch the
show I kind of forget that I was in it
no I feel I'd be remiss my King has
married and I owe my new queen a whit
Michele Fiori is such a brilliant
actress well Tom who actually plays the
the the guy that stabs my wife in the
stomach there and also prayed the
ex-soldier and bodyguard who tries to
kill the Home Secretary these arrows
roast Nikki and me before days just kind
of try never cook more coffee and you
just knock everything out I think
there's like a dance ice because you
can't go right first one that's here you
see like this and then you've got one
there I can see you like that but then
you go on in your leg so it's like that
kind of like a strange puppet down she
goes this is quite an emotional sequence
I mean just as an actor to do that kind
of watching your unborn child be
murdered and then your wife is only
dying in your arms not a comedy
[Music]
top tip shaving foam gets rid of fake
blood because it stains your skin so
that moment when I get stabbed in the
stomach I've got this hydraulic pump
with loads of fake blood and it's got a
little hole here so the blood goes and
but on the first take and it was just
totally mess time so I just had like I
don't know a few liters of fake blood
just pumped it's the inside of my
costume so I'm just kind of doing my
acting but realizing no Bloods coming
and I'm just getting colder and wetter
and stickier on the inside yeah there's
no sweating still sporting and then that
Scream she does years later my biggest
memory about the red wedding isn't so
much about the actual red wedding itself
it's about what happened after because
every time we would ramp up for a new
season getting ready for season 4 for
season 5 and then for season 6 and so on
is that people would wonder if Lady
Stoneheart would mysteriously surface
the hopes were bigger going into season
4 because it was right after and Lady
Stoneheart was supposed to surface
around that time in the book then the
conspiracy theory has started we got to
season 5 and people were like she still
has a chance she could still show up but
then finally the producers came out and
said no there were never any plans to
ever do Lady Stoneheart she was never on
the table they did try to pay this off
with Arya's reverse red wedding on the
phrase in season 7 episode 1 but that's
probably all we're gonna get from the
series about it I don't expect to ever
go back there but just a reminder if HBO
releases anything new for Game of
Thrones Season 8 between now and the end
of the year obviously I'll do a video
for it leave your requests in the
comments below
congratulations ruse 509 here's the
giveaway winner from my last big Game of
Thrones video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here for that
season 8 episode 1 preview video and
click here for that brand new Game of
Thrones season 8 HBO trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome
I'll see you
tonight
you